good morning everyone my name is
researcher Miller and today the SCP were
going to be studying is SCP 1507 object
class Euclid special containment
procedures SCP 1507 is to be contained
in wilderness observation cell 1b with
standard security procedures the
following text is stricken from the
document but I'll read it anyway
instances of scp-1583 P 1507 without
being accompanied by security any staff
members entering this enclosure must
wear protective clothing covering the
head and body access is only permitted
to inspect the cage and for research
purposes if SCP 1507 appears to be
vocalizing more frequently than is
considered normal the on-site sound
dampening speakers must be activated
until the vocalizations cease
description SCP 1507 is a set of 26
plastic lawn flamingo x' made in Coral
Springs Florida instances of scp-1583
burr but do not require feeding
instances of scp-1583 confirm the
document it says testing has shown they
do not possess a complex intelligence
hmm that's ominous instances of scp-1583
the enclosure by dropping down on them
using their metal stands to create
scratch wounds and puncture wounds in
their victims face and eyes SCP 1507
will frequently appear docile until it
attacks leading to several cases of
severe injury among research staff SCP
1507 was discovered on september 18th
1991 in jacksonville florida they first
came to the foundation's attention when
the foundation followed up on a 911
which the caller claimed to have been
attacked by several lawn flamingos the
following are audio recordings that were
recovered from an audio listening device
found installed inside the home
telephone of Arthur winds Worth during
the recovery operation of scp-1508
the origin of the listening device is
currently unknown investigation is
ongoing
Oh may I have your name well I'll see
what I can do in the future if you have
any more problems with please contact
the police department directly to file
report
[Applause]
oh right because I thought well I've
already filed a report
[Applause]
[Applause]
Oh
[Applause]
now
[Applause]
whatever
[Music]
when the house the call originated from
was investigated foundation operatives
found a man dead from poacher wounds
with 15 instances of scp-1583 can
portion of this paragraph amended see
incident 15:07 a and b addendum
incidents involving SCP 1507 incident
1507 - a SCP involved SCP 1507 location
wilderness observation cell 1b
description on the 12th of April 2011
researcher Boyd was playing with SCP
1507 - 8 during his break during this
time SCP 1507 - 8 playfully attempted to
take food from him taking this as an
aggressive action boyd knocked SCP 1507
- 8 to the floor cracking the plastic
shell of the creature after the incident
all instances of scp-1583 vision and in
the meantime all staff members must
exercise caution when going in to SCP
1507 enclosure and this is incident 1507
- be as he be involved SCP 1507 location
wilderness observation cell 1 be
description on the 6th of May 2011 SCP
1507 began to vocalize more frequently
in addition these vocalizations were
unique when compared to any previously
catalogue calls approximately 45 hours
after the new calls were first observed
11 new instances of scp-1583
- as SCP 1507 16 to 26 arrived at the
site and breached the containment of all
SCP 1507 instances they proceeded to
attack site personnel with previously
unseen levels of aggressive actions and
behavior during the breach they were
hostile towards staff members wounding
11 and causing 4 fatalities before being
rican tained realizing that other
instances of scp-1583 learnis
observation cell was upgraded with
soundproofing equipment SCP 1507 was
then upgraded to euclid status addendum
- it is currently hypothesized that SCP
243 or a similar anomaly may be a
possible origin for a CP 1507 it is
currently unknown why SCP 1507 as yet 2d
animate or if it will D animate in
accordance to SCP 243 s behavior in the
future investigation is ongoing
okay that about does it today folks
thank you very much for listening you
are all dismissed
goodbye I would like to give a special
thank you to Andre best shift
thank you very much Andre your pledge is
very much appreciated if you would like
to know how you can get a personalized
thank e at the end of each of my videos
as well as some other really cool stuff
as well go to patreon.com/scishow
[Music]
you
[Music]